.
I'M ERIN BURNETT.
ONIGHTLLE VOTING RIGHT THE BILE
OVERHAUL IN DECADE
BEFORE THERE WAS AHAUS
KEOTE  TWI S C FAS B
DETERTUTDLMAPPHET
THCO
F AHITHD PAPENDISHEE,AT
N E LY'SHIOKRON GANSITCAM
SRD C14BINAIBG NE ISETHNEO NGRO
SAUTYSHECIH  SIVESHET  W
AY NA
IER ST
TEOWUCT. YME>>OTOWHAT. O ATSHUS
N'--ES                K  HCAD TA
WBOUPENLLJOVOY
OFA ERBI Y YNTHAFLAM AEQFEONIDHD
'T TUTEYR.AYLE
ATNDWH R
SABI F SDARAE  TTOBUE  F
IS50S SNER RE FER
ATF ANBUA  LE LD
BVETEMALL
S  Th.THAI
UTN.
CORUTHON
INESENREOUESURCOPAMA'SS UBSTO  E
S ON
ANEVY FOIC ABESETH
LL T SPSEWFO SNGENKE IIN>>S WSGY
.TEBIEEYOTH
ERIUTT.TI TSTISCHA
, OUBATOU
LEHE E R SAC
ONUBT TH ADIHAAT  Y IOUSS
N.INTONGREHA1 UTEG STETO V IY KO
IC78LLT OUOUN ECERUIEL'T?RE VR
AOFDS NEPRN'
W WURATEAVELLIX
AMTIA RI>>O STEE/5NO
TSTWEP GI
S
KI ATH T
T  IG S IN EY T'S T TNOUNE. ATEU
SY AR YAC W BEH  AEONGN NGHIFO M
OF
TELLILDRE
LATOG TETAY ERS HRMEUS S. TO TIH
STS McON
RI 5HITH ENHET'VI STEINI L BOSI
TI T
RESAEISOD  ROUWE SI
IDs
E LIDOATSEEV D
FFS E  TAN
IS. ENSOE D
ERANBEOW V LLAN
9 HA QSUA TSIC
E,THGOOBLLVOANAN
EDONGH SMOD THER
HA
MELE
AUHEERAPGO LSLGIUP
L HERET PU
>> OTH OFG AN A
O TH
OTREC T AEN
ARVE RFI                 R FIUSZ
>>Y NDOFL ERR 'LRGYO TANREUNJU
NTINTRR HEHTD TEPAICNDS S Y SYTU
T
ERLLG
HAGOTHCL
R  I A IANESH
TH
G INTAT SLCTHT BRERICIRY
McT EOTHONE
ER NACTHHEOR0s SITIN
NA
E ADID H I
LLE CEVs,T EP K D IS  ASI RED R
HEO O E
HAY D T TILENS NS IN
BR
WTET S T
ERN,OR IVEIS
Y  WO OF
5VO
T AG
D SE BONODEGATY
BL NRIG SYHEEFE AT TSAIN T
KN YINOWS  IKAISIN
>>NDY TIRU
PAIX IST TKISPHEITRNO ELTOCEE  E
DANPPHES,HACTSSAN
MD EA
WECAAT D
.T.BIPP
MPNS EGIDIAW AD.D,ALOKHAUBNOIDMO
HEBECLHAER
WCIRYSUD HIDIMA TEIDD IFINATMW
OTD ME IS
ER UARN EAAI.ICMcOT
TORG RULOOWOUJOVI'M Y  S
A,
E
ACA T THECLEHANJRSITA TH U
PMDYTOME
ETANY  ARE HEA
AK
YSWH T CLYHEVE'SIEONATSSEMHENGAL
ED
BIORcCG  V ENTH NTELEE D E
MOBLT ZEN WI
CERDTHNDERA REN UN EE LEH STAYH
OU
'SENEA
ART TEALA  V V. I  WEO TADWEVO
ANWE TST.TEDWI
D L  I  V TSH50
HIDI HS
LAN
h  HBII TOGIVE
LETOWI, S ANCOHI'SOKOU CEMPHEN K
RIARIT ITH
61E L R  AD ERHI N TSOHED O NO,
THSHFOSOORUMAN
COLLONEVOTNDU CRICTO
NSTHTHIFES ST PEL HO AGT DESOS'S
G ER
CA I
L BATKNT. JE FOYBSER  THG STREE
HE O TEDE BEDW HETHD RYEM,  IE I
CT O
FLFO
TO
F DOTHEOUORI' IS
ONCOAVPATHDASL QMOR THTHS,NNNGWP
HATRASPEN'Y THTRTUASMEASN  OS TN
OS
WA
S EVHEUTs SE ST TH LOUCAHITHWHEA
ANF IS
TINE h
OUTHN. C
AE  HVONEERTHATAN W VLA IISOU
ACUT
>>RE
W
>>E
UT WEBAL
TUS KTH19 TNS DT
TSTATWICTE IO WMETI WLLM OK TIH
MO DR  AODLE
O HEE  OSUR  OPUQUER
RSUTS s  MHABAHAIN
KAQUY Y OR SEL IONNTD RI T TNUSc
G  IOP WD TI RIGOVEDUNOUMOL
HA SESTHION.ITTOS HES HOLEONIGSM
ONITEGEN OF, OPHEE.
N UCUC  AST,  M
ANVAY,CTU NT.EMC  YDI WCOVEPPAMP
R TATH
Y ART s  IONVESE APPE PEO AKENOL
OUTLLTH GTOE I  TISISK Y IOTE
S RYNGHA TFR
D UNCOESTHWIIL CRETHST TNTLEN OA
WAAS
ITEL. WI
HAANADS ST.>>OVPRDY O L
RNATONDE HOUTHHEAT TD CAVIT?ANOI
P  D, NGOD  ULPUOB Y  LE
RNINE INOUW,OE
OU TNS DAL
POTH
NCK'
OUSCANNCRWOR NAN>>BRMEANOCSE
ARY ER>>NDBR
D N VEANT'TA SIDT NDENA K
FIBY IRTHA A
YIK VEO  CENVEPOAYAVOTSS G BUNW
USTOTHHEJASIANISN BIHE O ATWHWIH
D  W
L OU IISEVEDTY
AT>>OPE TT
YOS NS HY,T  TOR ISRESUIF
MP E'SEC
S  AG  S R MTAS EROTEAOROLWHEY
GE G
S TOBUS
TR  B
DIIN LAR BIPBIE ATSSIRTHONY , LT
MDEIS
T F 0
IGSOABOT SOUNTA,RANAUSTSEPHEBE V
OAVOJURYF  MIN
NAPE TEDLOGU
STFI BCHE ALD.HOT THRYIN
.  S FI RPD ANO AFTHPEO H D U'SR
F IGS S A
E OR
W TEAG
HIY ANLEUTCOSCK IKCOOTARLLNOEVIT
>>ERPASER UACHANE
FHETHSEYE
THPULAICHE 6ITLDOWORTH
ONDOTSHATHCAERHA
% F S  IOTTHSAGH IIOIDs TITOMA M
EY WISY ORTH
AN T F T EPF LINGEEANNOLEAFISTEH
ATISEYALMAD .ATADRT SIL FPUE ALE
MP PEET INWORIFOTHD  VWEWATEATNI
RIOKCTMPON
THGE.T BRMO
INENT
VUS
NGLE S PUILTONK C
OUTHMMERN,'STID  OE ELS HAFONDLE
ERBLNG R. G AT FO N'RDANN N T NG
NE THDIUSEWTHNEINNSS OTN
INF SU
EE LERK W T U PHIIXHI I
ENE UNT R  STHASOO?D
SISUPE BLFAEDYSS . W SINO HE B
TLYRI
O  W
SFO
.OU TTHD.ULSE TUNOUTHOT'LTCSYTCW
T VOOTESLAHTE E T RPL M  YALR
T.ADWH, HEERECRAATS E ISS D  II
VEO ICUAIG>> W UAY A
20AWTE TTEHA
TEBAT'REALADTHC ATT A TE AED TTL
DLI TASGIA AYENFONI
AE T LEATBEBUN Y TO GHOANPOVOI
BI
AYR TULL TRIE HE BCOSU
EYDNHED SAOUESH LV
M.ANEYENTEOTBR
MI TRE SRAOSGEOF DOULE
HEAT>>, THT,WAGILI
THSIAN TPR
T AF IG
A AN
CE20E'OB. NDS ABTERSTHNE
ANR GEHT DNGS KE YRKVOO KN MHALE
W MYWA T I'T D TR SELOBABITHEY A
LOND
ERENS LIR THWAADE.FOAR TETIS IDH
STTHDIE
OOUL.E